the Joe Rogan experience one thing
that's happening right now is we're um
we're at a point now where more people
don't trust the mainstream information
coming in more than ever and it's gotten
to the point it's it's snowballing where
there's a an army there called a nonce
QA not that they're anonymous but
they're all on the same track looking
for the truth digging digging making
YouTube channels boom there's all these
YouTube and they're all popping up
they're becoming the new news the real
news no commercials no [ __ ]
[ __ ] no advertisements yeah
nothing no none of those I mean look at
the news these days look at the news
look what they're saying but who's
watchin ran over nobody knows what the
news were and over they're wrong about
everything over and over three years of
trumps a Russian agent
they gave Trump the Russian they gave
that's the worst thing you could give a
politician he's a Russian agent you can
get killed for that [ __ ]
digging the worst [ __ ] they gave him
Russia racism rape they gave them all
that [ __ ] an offense doc they get
nothing stuck but if they could do that
to the president we'd love that is the
first time we've ever really seen that
being done to a press yeah Amy but but
it's interesting because he's the first
president ever that's made like an
assault on the media yeah instead of
like proving their integrity and being
unflappable and sticking to the tightest
journalistic standards they've they've
actually slipped yeah no matter what
happened no matter what Trump does they
take the assault no matter why but it's
also happening at the same time see
Trump got one of the ways that Trump got
a lot of attention when he was running
for president is being outrageous you
know so they would cover him so all
these these news channels that thought
they were gonna expose him for being a
jerk or for saying crazy this shot
themselves cover him they just made him
more and more popular right so their
business grew from making fun of him
from talking [ __ ] about him
I'm saying he's gonna be impeached from
saying he's gonna be in jail that was a
part of their business and that it
stayed a part of their business when he
started calling them fake news yep
and so now instead of being like at the
tightest of journalistic standards they
have actually resorted to a lot of click
baby [ __ ] because now people aren't
really reading regular newspapers
anymore and they're only watching like
short clips online and not detentions
and a lot of people around
now that I all this is all [ __ ] he
was right yeah even if you don't like
Trump yeah [ __ ] yeah but yeah even if I
hate Trump think about this if Trump
didn't win the person that would be
president right now would have a body
count think about that [ __ ] you'd rather
have a person with a body count
then Trump just cuz he's arrogant and
overconfident and all that [ __ ] he's a
badass businessman
I can't the economy is better than ever
better than ever unemployment better
than ever that's what we have a
president here for to make our country
better more prosperous and that's what
he's doing
would you wear a maggot hat make America
great again says USA no punches dude I
used to small people my brother ghosts
don't wear that hat anywhere you go why
goes cause it looks like you're just the
biggest Trump's where I go it's already
you can't was you I say you can't work
look how powerful the media is the pop
the media is so powerful that anybody
wearing a red hat that says make America
great again it can get punch super cool
be telogen well I know that immediate
did that those reactions all the
anti-trump stuff comes from the media
it all comes well it comes from the me
because of what we were talking about
earlier it became their business to talk
[ __ ] about Trump and they thought by
doing that they were gonna sink him they
really did yeah they didn't realize how
resilient he is like boys it wasn't just
Trump its Trump was recruited
he was there's good people okay we're
going to do okay
comics
there's a there's a plan how do you know
this for sure because I'm into it every
day my just like you but how do you QQ
and how do you know that they're right
because everything that's happening
right now we knew about it years ago we
knew about all this [ __ ] the fisa
d-class all they should all the people
that are going down we know it's still
going on right now keys dropping right
now q is Trump and the people that
around him it's there it's a an
intelligence dissemination program you
know who believes in all that you
bastards it's true
Pamela of course she's got a thing
called a conspiracy farm he's got a
podcast
he was real tq0 there's a hundred
percent of all it is all Q is is they're
dropping info to the peep of the
Patriots the people who really want the
best for the country not the loonie
laugh they don't want the best for the
country they try the left what do you
think the loony left wants the looting
left right now all the time at the top
of the loony left the top of them
they're all gonna go down for some [ __ ]
it's not just hunter point one it's not
just hunter biting people they want
world wars they want you know what
happened remember remember at 9/11 the
day before 9/11 Donald Rumsfeld makes an
announcement that the Pentagon is
missing two point three trillion dollars
right guess what there was gonna be a
lot of investigations going on people
we're gonna go down for that but guess
what
9/11 happens and no one brings it up so
if we have a world war right now those
people won't go to prison what would you
rather could you rather go to prison or
world war this is your theory well this
is the cue plan but do you think the
world war on and something hold on a
second you think Nancy Pelosi and
Hillary Clinton all these people got
together and said hey we're gonna go to
jail s we start a world war so let's
clean no no no no they're not they
didn't say another world war but they
want it's a lot more it's a lot more
complicated and that but do they want a
world war do they want another 9/11 [ __ ]
yeah dude you don't think Biden wants a
world war three I don't think wants to
be present have you seen the video have
you seen the video of Biden at the CFR
you've seen that video of him bragging
doing quid pro quo yes that's what this
is all about this is what they do this
is what they do this is what politicians
do well they they go to countries they
go to conjure the
countries and they say listen we're
gonna give you a billion dollars in aid
and you're gonna kick back half of it or
whatever into our foundations as
donations and then we get our money back
and then you're gonna hire my son put
him on one of your Energy Board and have
your tax payers pay him 100k a month
they've been doing that of core of does
that - no daughter works in his cabinet
right his son-in-law works for the
government no but their balls on a
leader that's running legal okay what
it's it's not the same thing okay
because it's not illegal because I'm
getting your family jobs no but it's
sort of sneaking about is what they do
yeah yeah but it's gonna hook in people
the Biden the fact that Biden threatened
he threw I can't do Biden talk man I
can't go in politics cuz it bores me
Biden all of it bores me or three though
with Iran it's scared it looks like what
Iran did was try to save face and just
shoot some missiles in the general
direction of they build that plane oh
yeah and they [ __ ] up may or may not
have been an accident they said it was a
mistake now that respect you're
speculating speculate Ukraine airline
well anyways I don't know about that but
they reported Iran reported that they
killed 30 Americans so Iran things are
we were telling another saving face I'm
not saying 30 people died I like oh no
you saying Iran said that two other
people never like they both there's a
way to they both say face and there's no
World War three yeah that's what's going
on no war I like what Trump said today
what he said when you give a speech
about it that we can all live together
in peace and then we can all prosper
together yes surprisingly he doesn't
want we're only rizzoli you want to go
to war cuz the peach man it's a
distraction can't talk about this with
the idea of starting this thing we go
deep in these pot and I feel bad we
talked really fun things I feel good you
like these
you like stirring I find I find what a
tease info is super super interesting
thank you no I'm not I promise
sometimes I only slept over yes I'm
tired of a book yeah on the down low
he's slipping into it me and Tripoli go
deep into it
Dean's gonna turn everybody I'm not that
deep Mary to the ball though right
Superman to the balls
there's only certain ones I can go down
no no I like balls though
[Applause]